willkommen zurück bei Bild live an
diesem Donnerstag 10.000 gegen Putin
Demonstrationen gegen den Krieg und vor
allem dagegen das Putin jetzt 300.000
weitere Russen in die Ukraine schicken
will Väter Söhne Onkel und das was Sie
hier sehen das ist die Reaktion darauf
in den Straßen nein zum Krieg rufen
diese Menschen hier auf den Straßen
moskauz und ganz ähnliche Bilder kommen
aus den vergangenen Stunden aus nahezu
allen Großstädten Russlands aus St
Petersburg aus Kaliningrad und und und
und überall Festnahmen insgesamt heißt
es rund 1.500 die Polizei wie gewohnt
die greift hart teilweise brutal durch
gegen diese
antiputin-proteste hier sehen Sie wie
aus dem Restaurant raus mit dem Handy
gefilmt wird wie ein demonstranter
niedergeprügelt
niedergeknüppelt wird der Protest gegen
den Krieg in der Ukraine bisher haben
die Russen ja ganz überwiegend diesen
Krieg mitgetragen sie selbst
ehrlicherweise hatten damit aber auch
nicht viel am Hut und jetzt lässt Putin
aber teil kritisieren jetzt also kommen
die einberufungsbefehle zu Hause an und
das wollen die Russen dann eben doch
nicht mehr sie fangen an sich zu wehren
hier in den Straßen da singen russische
Mütter hören Sie sie singen unsere
Kinder sie sollen leben also da geht es
gegen die Einberufung ihrer Söhne
tja
jetzt geht also die Angst um bei vielen
Russen bin auch ich einer von 300.000
die jetzt in den Krieg ziehen müssen das
will niemand schon gar nicht jemand der
im direkten Umfeld von Putin bisher ganz
wunderbar und Fett gelebt hat wie zum
Beispiel der Dimitri peskov und seine
Familie die mit repezko das ist einer
der engsten Vertrauten Putins sie sehen
Sie ihn hier mit Putin gemeinsam seit
zehn Jahren ist er sein Sprecher und
dieser Dimitri peskov der hat einen Sohn
Nicolai rechts im Bild Nikolai Peskow
was ist wenn man den jetzt in den Krieg
einzieht ein russischer YouTube-Kanal
hat genau das getestet Anruf beim Sohn
des putinsprechers sorry wir müssen Sie
hiermit in den Krieg einziehen
hallo hallo Nikolai
wer ist denn da hier spricht der
militärkommissar mit dir kannst du reden
ja kann ich sehr gut dann leg bitte
nicht wieder auf wie beim letzten Mal
aber warum rufen Sie mich an und warum
sagen sie ich soll dran bleiben
ich rufe sie an weil heute verkündet
wurde dass sie eingezogen werden und sie
haben einen Brief mit einer Nummer
bekommen die sie noch nicht angerufen
haben sie sollen morgen um 10 Uhr zum
militärkommissariat kommen also wir
rufen Sie an weil sie sich erstens nicht
gemeldet haben und zweitens morgen
erscheinen müssen
also ich kann morgen um 10 Uhr nicht
kommen also sie müssen verstehen dass
ich peskov bin und nicht richtig ist für
mich dort zu sein und überhaupt
ich werde das Lösen ich werde das aber
auf einer anderen Ebene lösen
also dieser Anruf der zeigt mitmachen
will bei diesem brutalen Krieg natürlich
keiner paronsheimer unser Bild Reporter
in der Ukraine nein zum Krieg auch in
Russland jetzt zumindest dann wenn er
einen jetzt plötzlich persönlich
betrifft
ja absolut Kai das bringt die Stimmung
in Russland auf den Punkt und es bringt
auch die Arroganz der Macht auf den
Punkt die Arroganz von Putins Regime und
das ganze könnte dann diesen Regime und
Putin noch mal auf die Füße fallen denn
man merkt dass die Proteste zunehmen ob
das am Ende tatsächlich
reicht um irgendetwas zu bewegen das ist
offen das sieht zumindest momentan nicht
danach aus sondern da wird einfach
rigide durchgegriffen aber es zeigt eben
dass die Menschen diesen Krieg wenn Sie
persönlich betroffen sind diesen Krieg
auch nicht wollen
[Musik]